rachel is in Dallas Rachel welcome to
the day were mg show thank you what's up
[Music]
on that and my husband wants to buy a
house because he's tired of paying money
into rent every month and she wants it
to go into something you know isn't more
of an investment and so I'm but we can't
because they like that total income
ratio good so you don't need to buy a
house your bro yeah yeah and so you need
to rent as cheap as you can possibly
rent and begin to attack these student
loans what's your household income 102
yeah okay
what do you guys do for a living he's a
chiropractor and just like an admin okay
and how much taken loan debt do you all
have 360,000 oh my god yeah how much of
that is just chiropractic she didn't
want to be a dentist and so that he went
to car parks at school and became a
chiropractor so like about over a
hundred thousand of it is chiropractic
and the rest is the dental so none of it
you know I already paid off my student
loan debt before we got married okay and
how long has she been a chiropractor
[Music]
seven years and he makes what what does
he make a hell
you said the mouse will be 102 thirty
and he makes 72 he makes seven eight yes
so he's at the bottom range of what
chiropractors make after seven years
what are we going to do to get his
practice going he is you know he's he
works for someone else yeah but there's
lots of chiropractors that work for
someone else that make 100
yeah in Dallas Texas
yeah and you need to do that since you
spent all this freaking money on student
loans so we got to get your income up
for one thing and then you guys are
gonna start living like you're broke and
putting all your money on that as fast
as you can
Rachel if you guys do not become very
very serious about this this is gonna
overwhelm your family and set you back
decades yeah you're gonna have to become
very serious I don't want you freaked
out I don't what you worried but I want
you extremely focused and angry at that
debt both you and him he's just as
lackadaisical as he can be I can tell by
the way this whole story's going down
and I'm not okay with that run up 360
thousand dollars in debt and sit on your
thumbs
that won't work kiddo you don't have to
get with it here you have to get mad and
focused and not at him and him not at
you but focused and because this is a
mess this is a mess he has made a mess
and you're have to clean it up it's not
going away there's no magic student loan
fairy